Thank you to Mike and to Google for
inviting me in today to talk about my very
personal journey down the rabbit hole
of Emoji over the last 18 months,
the sequence of events which led me to
the creation of the woman's blue flat
shoe and my subsequent conviction in
the power of Emoji to enrich the pop
cultural landscape and simultaneously
be a very subtle catalyst for change.
As an image emoji enthusiast,
it's great fun for me to think about
this vision visual lexicon which has
exploded and more importantly
where it's going. However,
it's very much a new area for me.
Had someone told me 18 months ago that I
would create an Emoji that would become
acquisio lab and be anointed
as a feminist symbol,
I genuinely would have
chuckled and yet here we are.
When I look at this little Emoji available
and over 20 billion smart connected
devices across the globe,
I see my worldview reflected and
represented in a small yet perfect little
illustration.
That worldview is the product
of my twin occupations.
The first as a fiercely committed mother
to four young daughters and the second
as a media strategist within the
arts and culture sphere. As a mother,
I spent a lot of time thinking about
early childhood language acquisition and
screen time literacy and implicit
gender bias is faced by women in all age
groups.
As an arts professional,
I have a profound belief and deep
conviction and the knowledge produced by
artists and they're unparalleled ability
to tap into the psych guys before many
others do.
So I do also see the world and
experience it through a very visual lens.
It isn't that paradigm and the combination
of these two occupations that led me
to this little Emoji that
launched a thousand thoughts.
Bear with me as I try to tackle
a few of them. As I mentioned,
I am the mother to these four formidable
daughters ranging from seven years old
to 10 weeks.
However,
stepping back to spring 2017 I was chess
beginning to reemerge from the newborn
vortex as my third daughter,
the blonde started inching her way
towards sleeping through the night.
She had joined us in November of 2016
on election night no less and was our
first us born child by May,
2017 my partner and I had finally
arrived at that happy equilibrium in the
family dynamic where one of you
following the addition of a new child is
actually comfortable being left
alone with all of your children
and so on.
This glorious weekend in May,
I tore through my way through some
very unglamorous but highly practical
Saturday chores mostly related
to those with domestic sphere.
Our first stop was the local
grocery store. Now keep in mind,
we all live in Palo Alto where the produce
is incredible and this presentation
is something of a visual feast.
Yeah.
My Saturday morning shopping in
no way resembles alert. Sure, yes.
The UX quite the opposite.
It's more of a military
grade blitzkrieg operation.
On this particular day as I grabbed the
shopping cart to where's my kids around
the produce section,
I instructed our two older girls who are
five and three at the time to sit down
near the book carousel era. Yet.
Our local grocery store. Yes,
there are books for
children there and yes,
my children sit down on the floor and
read them while I try and choose our
fruits and vegetables. Now normally
this would be done in lightening speed,
but that morning are happy.
Chaos was abruptly interrupted.
The book that both of my children had
chosen was this one polite as a princess.
I tried all be it in vain
for a few seconds and my
sleep deprived Hayes to turn
the carousel and look for its male
counterpart, polite as a prince.
Extra come as no surprise that it
didn't exist. It still doesn't.
So I removed the bucks
from my daughter's hands,
place them in the cart and
made my way the checkout lane.
Well simultaneously expressing
my disappointment with
this book using Disney's
Instagram Hashtag
next up we crossed the street.
It's our local baby boutique where on
my punch list with the desire to replace
my existing baby carrier,
which was now five years
old and egregiously stained
because sure they have the
design and the materials had gone through
some innovations since I originally
bought mine.
As I reviewed the new options and there
were literally 20 boxes on the shelves,
I had an alarming realization.
Only one package among the 20 depicted
a male figure toting his child.
It was a Norwegian brand called stocky.
It seemed that only Norwegian fathers
carried their children frustrated by this
visual reminder that women are expected
to literally carry the brunt of child
rearing responsibilities.
I hot stepped out of the store with
my three daughters and went home.
As a side note,
this very topic became something of a
rather viral episode a few months ago,
which some of you may have seen when
Piers Morgan took to Twitter, Twitter,
and insulted Daniel Craig, a
k bond for toting his kid. Um,
in a similar spirit that Wall Street
Journal recently published a huge feature
on male focus designed carriers displaying
such masculine motifs of camouflage
and neutral color ways.
It would only be later that
night as I was nursing the baby,
while everyone was asleep,
that the stilettos appearance became the
mod that broke the proverbial camel's
back. I was sending a message to a friend
in Europe when I type the seemingly
innocuous word shoe,
and it was the first time that I noticed
that Emoji auto populated and this was
what appeared and in it I saw
the final visual reminder.
This time in the view
that virtual universe,
that of all the unrealistic
expectations bestowed upon women,
how does one begin to unpack the litany
of thoughts that entered my mind at 3:00
AM when I saw this symbol,
this small little picture that
said to me that we as women,
I expect it to lock the
world in high heels.
I think this is a great place to start.
This is a work by a hot young artists,
male artists name Torbjorn.
Roland was represented by David Carr,
Gansky gallery in Los Angeles.
In this singular image, the
stiletto evokes danger, seduction,
provocation with more than
a soup soon with pain.
It's a tool of power
which women off to own.
Okay.
Yeah. This was my reality. This
photograph is by Vivian Maier,
who some of you may have
seen the documentary and
it's very much like most of
her photographic,
Ugh,
anonymous that was showing this women
who was anonymously shot without the
consent of the subject in the 70s this
woman in Manhattan is wearing that shoe
and is literally injured and has even
gone to the lengths of crafting a heel for
her cast.
And so I began to ask myself whether
my aversions to stilettos with simply a
unique byproduct of spending literally
the last eight years, either pregnant,
carrying a baby on my torso, pushing
a stroller, or bending over, well,
helping a little person learn to walk.
In other words,
was my mom attire in the footwear
category, an isolated experience.
The resounding answer after weeks of
research, which was ultimately informed,
my emoji proposal was no,
it was not isolated.
I started looking at the history of
footwear and what I under very quickly was
that the red high heel and all of its
implications that accompany it date back
at least 70 years to the days of mad men.
The following is a small sampling
of the vintage. As I unearth.
I particularly liked this one,
which is actually an editorial from the
New Yorker magazine in the 1950s can
anyone guess who it is?
It's Andy Warhol.
Not only is it done by Warhol,
but the red high heel is literally
equated with success for female workers in
New York City.
Interestingly,
I actually discovered this spread on the
Whitney's Instagram stories from their
current major Warhol retrospective,
the first and over 30 years.
Shifting my gaze from
historical ads and editorials,
I turned my eye to the contemporary and
started examining how footwear is used
to communicate to women today,
and what I found was that we have
made no progress in many ways.
I think it's actually worsened.
Okay.
Here's an ad from the breastfeeding
lobbying group in the UK in which you can
save your money from formula
to be a yummy or money.
Here's one from Clinique.
I would challenge to ask,
where's the comfort in the Red Stiletto?
Okay.
In this Geico ad,
women are literally encouraged to switch
their insurance policy so they can
famously save, redeploy said savings.
To the things they love. Red Pumps.
Interestingly, the male counterpart of
this ad, which appears in men's magazines,
is a big hunk of steak
in this one.
Another great export from the UK.
The National Service Health
Service Equates motherhood
with the abandonment of a
very specific version of female hood.
Here we have the TSA espousing
better convenience at the
airport while traveling.
Yet I would challenge that the most
inconvenient part of removing shoes is
actually shoes with
laces, not the heel. Plus,
I don't know many women who actually
wear heels well traipsing across the
airport.
Okay.
The U s postal service equates fashion
with high heels and suggest that neither
fashion nor the post
office rest on Sundays.
Zappos a category buster, which I'll
return to later in the footwear space,
suggest that women all love red stilettos.
Barclays in urging financial
literacy and acumen, again,
suggest that those funds that you
save should be spent on shoes.
Okay.
The newly launched magazine,
which went viral earlier this month and
some of you may have seen because of a
sensationalist image of Rachel
McAdams pumping and designer.
Where has this tagline bringing
back the woman stiletto?
I find it ironic given
the title of the magazine.
Okay.
For giving Tuesday,
Bruno Maglio donated a hundred pairs
of these burgundy's Suede Stilettos,
their name to the gala pump.
Now I would venture to say that a
woman who is new to the job search and
interview process should have one
fewer thing to be thinking about,
which is learning to walk
if in six inch stilettos.
Of course,
we're here at Google and one of my
very first places when I went down that
rabbit hole was to look at
Google Arts and culture.
This shoe is an item of four were intended
to protect and comfort the human foot
while the where is doing various
activities, and I don't know about you,
but nothing about this shoe made me
think of comfort or walking to Google's
credit within 24 hours of me instagramming
it. Come on Google, you can do better.
They changed it.
It's now a raggedy old booth.
This is a sense that was recently launched
by Carolina Herrera and wait for it.
It's called good girl.
Okay.
The text used to, uh, to get
women to buy it says it all.
It's good to be bad, provocative,
intent, lethal charisma,
seductive charisma, and there's no
escape. It's about ruthless power.
Now that we've spent some time
investigating how stilettos are generally
depicted and the way,
the expectations that they carry
with them as a visual emblem,
I wanted to talk also by my
observations with Emoji specifically,
which have been formed through
the eyes of my young children.
As I mentioned at the, I was very
much an Emoji novice 18 months ago.
Only the casual sort of kissed sending
face or the heart appeared in my text
messaging. Yet this all changed when
my children began attending school.
And suddenly emojis seem
to be literally everywhere.
So let's talk about how much my children
love Emoji and how omnipresent they are
in their daily existence.
Because in many ways,
the impetus to create my
flat shoe Emoji was one,
driven by parental
responsibility and duty.
If my kids were going to be using Emoji
and seeing them repeatedly in their
routines,
shouldn't I at least try to create
some semblance of balance to the three
existing high heeled options that existed?
Yeah,
there was a peril.
Okay.
You can make bracelets with Emoji,
you can wear your Emoji to school,
you can keep your inner most thoughts
and an Emoji diary and if you don't feel
like describing your emotions,
you can use the Emoji stickers.
Okay.
You can get national geographic to
help you decode the Emoji language.
Literally at this point I had accepted
that my children were using Emoji,
not necessarily as a language
but as an expressive play thing.
So I turned to the other world that I
know and love and occupy the arts and I
started thinking about how artists were
engaging with the subject matter and it
became very clear that they too were
questioning the broader sentiment.
That emoji were simple little play things,
throwaways,
a trend to be dismissed and outgrown
the original Emoji set here,
which I'm sure many of you know,
it seems like a really good
place to start released.
Exactly 20 years ago in 1999
and including 176 Emoji.
It's acquisition by Moma.
Last year it was certainly viewed
as a legitimizing watershed moment.
Moments collection in New York is filled
with examples of design innovations
that radically altered our world,
so for Emoji,
including the little red pixelated
stiletto next to the scissors and the
hamburger to be come. Part of that
collection was historically significant.
Now that institutional
backing was in place.
I was really curious about
how artists themselves,
we're dealing with Emoji today.
Yeah.
I first came across this image last
August via Mary Boone Galleries Instagram
page. It depicts the fist and the
painting nail Emoji and my curiosity,
as you can imagine, was immediately
piqued. The work is by Derek Adams,
a young African American multidisciplinary
artist based in Brooklyn who might
have been following for some time when
I contacted the gallery a few weeks ago.
For the purpose of this presentation
and to learn more about this painting,
it emerged.
That is actually part of a whole new
body of work which will be shown in March
entitled new icons through multiple
layers of CNC applied paint and also by
hand.
Derek has purposely mimicked the digital
world and he's created this new series
of portraits using only the Emoji
library as a point of reference to an
individual that because of
his or her radical nature,
Adam's feels is important
to American popular culture.
This specific work is of a woman named
sister Souljah with some of you might
know is an author activist and was known
for the sister Souljah and move moment
during the Bill Clinton
presidential campaign.
So here we have a highly engaged artist
exploring the force of popular culture
and the media on the perception
and construction of self
image using Emoji as a
vehicle and a whole new
form of portraiture.
Okay,
next up I looked to Laura Owens,
the brilliant female artist in La who
is known for her large scale paintings
that intertwine art historical
references with painterly techniques.
I was fascinated by this installation
from 2015 in a club called the dirty rag
soccer club club in Chicago,
which is an exhibition space
and the former Polish soccer bar
and it Owen's installed hundreds of
these emoji ceramic sculptures above the
fully functional bar office at
her paintings there were literate,
she made by hand 426 Emoji sculptures
and they're 383 of them which are
available if anybody wants to buy
when I'm taking it one step further.
Actually last November in 2017 to coincide
with her major retrospective at the
Whitney Museum,
they went up to it and they clever.
They converted each of these Emoji into
a free digital sticker pack,
which I love and use incessantly.
And another example of a contemporary
artist incorporating Emoji.
I turned to Trevor Paglen,
the Macarthur Genius Prize winner and
previous artist in resident at Stanford's
cantor art center.
Haglin is widely known for an artistic
practice which seeks to expose and
investigate areas that don't wish
to be examined. Surveillance,
military operations,
intelligence.
He played a crucial whirl and with Laura
Poitras and citizen four and his body
of work is currently on show at the
Smithsonian and a major mid career survey
exhibition. This specific work
known as the symbology series,
looks at the totemic visual language
inherent in military culture.
Okay.
A typical uniform will sport patches
identifying its where its job program,
affiliation, achievements and
place. Within that hierarchy,
these markers of identity and program
heraldry begin to create a very peculiar
symbolic regime when they,
they picked ones affiliation with that,
with what the defense industry
insiders called the black world,
the world of classified programs,
projects and places whose outlines and
even existence our deeply held secrets.
Okay.
And finally I turned to the
legendary John Baldessari,
who at 87 years old remains
as forward thinking,
has ever known for using found imagery
that he recomposes by carefully selecting
pictures,
pairing them with text,
and often overlaying them with large
dots and swaths of color to mask or bring
attention to the areas of detail.
For this series of paintings.
He focused on the Animal
Emoji specifically taking
this interest in issues of
context and cultural specificity.
Further,
the new emoji series
evaluated the ubiquitous,
seemingly innocuous images that
we use in everyday conversations
and then this past November
Baldisari they a new emoji series.
Some of the text is ironic and suggestive
while some seem completely random,
thus challenging the viewer to make
sense out of the pairings. Well,
emojis are indeed straightforward images
that take the place of their real life
words Baldessari his work
seemed to suggest that their
meanings are not actually
set and I'd rather
subject to interpretation.
These universal images that
transcend cultural, social,
and linguistic boundaries are easily
subverted when removed from their iPhone
context and paired within different text.
Okay.
Even the hyper bright white background
of the works seems to recall the lighting
of the phone background where
these are typically seen.
Thus making the artwork itself represents
something beyond its material nature.
If you're curious,
the peaches sold out.
Yeah.
More recently,
a couple of weeks ago,
the Prado Museum in Madrid released
its own bespoke Emoji via Twitter to
celebrate its 200 anniversary.
So if you hashtag add the product 200
you immediately got this wonderful light
button.
Segwaying now from the art world context
and into the unexpected applications of
Emoji.
Here you have an example of actual
text being translated into Emoji,
which made me think we'll Google
translate offer that service.
Okay.
The traditional Emoji naitivity when which
went around and was widely circulated
during the holidays.
Okay.
A portmanteau of Emoji to
describe that sensation.
Many of us are currently
feeling back at work.
Okay.
This is one of my favorites.
Shopping by Emoji again, Zappos.
So if you go into the Zappos App,
you can actually shot by Emoji,
but unfortunately, if you're a
woman who's looking for a flat shoe,
it's not readily visible. However, the
next few screens do show what you get.
When you put in,
say the Mermaid Emoji and the lips Emoji.
I did contact Zappos,
they assure me it's in there now.
So if you put in my little flat shoe,
you get pages and pages of ballet flats.
This is a page from the December
issue of Elle magazine. Again,
shopping for your loved ones
based on their emoji usage.
I found this on Instagram.
Okay.
This one also went viral,
which is quite fun and entertaining,
looking at emoji usage on
a national country level.
And they began to make me think,
hmm,
our emoji usage actually
sort of the national psyche.
And what does that mean for profiling?
There's a good aspect of emoji targeting
like this endangered species campaign.
And for those of you that don't know,
you can actually buy emoji usage data
from Twitter and then use it for your
marketing campaigns. So while this is
a fantastic illustration of that tool,
another option is you're sitting watching
the Superbowl and you're tweeting at
your friend that you're about to order
pizza and you get a discount code from
Domino's.
And then the next week you get a discount
code for Jenny Craig for a weight loss
program. Another unexpected byproduct. My,
my Emoji journey was learning that
at the University of Michigan,
within the art history department,
there exist a class for
undergraduates called Emoji worlds.
It's taught by Jim [inaudible] who has
a phd in art history and a specialty in
Asian art contemporary,
but also has a JD from Yale law school.
And this class,
um,
spends about 12 weeks looking at
every aspect of Emoji for their final
assignment.
They were each required to submit an
Emoji proposal and guaranteed the Ne plus
by the way,
if it got adopted.
Sure.
And with this image, I want to finish
on the significance of design thinking.
Everything about this
crosswalk makes me smile.
It's insane.
And yet the design and interpretation
of my emoji across some platforms was
absolutely disheartening as though the
intent of the Emoji at its very core had
been completely overlooked.
I'll let you guess which ones.
When John Baldessari was asked about his
new emoji series, he wants responded.
That Emoji to him represented the most
Democrat Democratic living language.
It is crowdsourced after all
and that every time you use one,
you are in essence casting a vote.
With that thought.
I wanted to point out the
design difference in the
newly adopted brick Emoji and
leave you to thinking about
what vote you are casting.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming
to Google. Uh, and uh,
telling your story that it's fascinating
to me every time I hear it. So I mean,
I really, really appreciate
it. Thank you. Um,
I wasn't going to ask
you which implementation,
I mean you've been all over with this
Emoji campaign now that you see it in real
life. Um, which implementation
are you the happiest with?
I won't ask you which one you don't like
flipping it. That was pretty obvious.
I think the apple Emoji was the truest
to the initial design. I said my dad,
it was Prussian blue,
which was a very concerned choice,
um, to sort of flip on its head.
The whole idea of blue is for boys,
pink is for girls. Um, and I also,
one of the sort of unexpected surprises
that I loved actually about the Apple
Emoji is that where all the other shoes
are actually displayed at a 45 degree
tilt, apple went further and
truly made it flat and horizontal,
which wasn't something I had considered
and yet it really accentuates the
flatness of it.
Um,
I also loved that within the Apple
Emoji architecture and order,
the flat sheet actually
precedes the Stiletto.
So when you scroll through
the apparel category,
the flat shoe is the very first
one and that made me smile a lot.
That's great.
Can you tell us a little bit,
you told me about how you actually went
about designing the flat shoe emerging
in the first place. Um, you,
you spoke to an artist friend and then
you had some very specific requirements
of how you want it drawn and why you
wanted it to pick it a certain way.
I thought it was really interesting.
So I reached out to a graphic designer
named Afi masseur who had been the
illustrator for the woman
with a headscarf, otherwise
known as the Hijab Emoji.
And coincidentally is also a
children's book illustrator.
And I thought she would perfectly
get what I was trying to get at.
Um, and my directors were
really quite open. Um,
I absolutely wanted to not to be pink.
So I said you can choose the colors,
but it needs to be gender neutral.
Um,
I wanted both options to be available
in terms of a flat with a bow and one
without. Um, some people have asked
me, why did you include the bow?
It's such an overtly feminine thing.
And the reality is in my
research of flat shoes,
all of the original flats had
that binding to keep the shoe on.
And so it was actually a reference to
the historical design, a flat shoes,
which of course are also women by men.
Um,
and so I really wanted the
ultimate designers to have
the option of both a flat
with a bow and one without, and
there were six color ways, um,
and I wanted the heel to be
as non existent as possible
while still translating
on a micro scale.
Hmm. So you submitted several
versions of this to the Unicode?
Yeah. So I submitted two silhouettes,
one with the bow and one without,
and each silhouette was available in
six colors, which ranged from dark blue,
dark green, nude, Brown, black.
Hmm.
So it's fascinating is that you approached
the whole Emoji proposal from the art
world perspective, um, because
you're not in tech like,
like everybody here and you,
you taught yourself how to propose to
Unicode and you wrote the whole proposal
yourself, right? What was that like?
Like where did you start when you said
I wanted to get this Emoji accepted and
adopted?
Did you even know there was a Unicorn
Organization that you had to apply to and
how did you,
how did you start that whole journey?
It was a really fun,
um,
I get goosebumps thinking about it
because I had an excuse to get back on of
that student learning curve
and nerd out really. Um,
and it all kind of happened when no one
was looking in the middle of the night
because until that red
stiletto auto populated,
I had no idea how Emoji were made.
I literally held my phone and I was like,
hmm, it's apple. So smart that this
device has some sort of mythic,
a I that knows what my shopping habits
have been for the last 12 months has
aggregated that and therefore
this device knows this, this FEMA,
there's a female holding this phone and
has predicted that this is the stiletto,
that this is the shoe emoji
that's going to resonate with me.
That was literally my justification
rationale and then I thank you Google went
down the rabbit hole of
how I literally typed in,
how do emoji get made and that's when
I let it on the most horrific unicode
consortium. What page and sort of
navigated my way through the lake.
How does one submit a proposal on?
That's when my light bulb moment went off,
which was,
oh wait a second,
Emoji or crowdsourced anyone from me
and Palo Alto to an 85 year old man in
India to 15 year old girl in
Berlin can submit a proposal.
They just need to fill out this template.
And then once I realized that I'm actually
from a friend of mine who's in the
audience, I reached out to
the dumpling emoji creator,
Jennifer eight, Lee and cold emailed
her from her website and said,
this is my idea. This is
my observation. Am I crazy?
And with a matter of hours, she came
back to me and very succinctly said,
this is a good idea.
The deadline is July 1st.
And so at this point
it was June. Um, and I,
how can I sell it? Okay, I've
actually vocalize this to someone.
I now have my marching orders,
no pun intended.
And I spent basically the next three
weeks putting together the proposal
entirely on my own. Um, and
it was really fun. Um, the,
the one thing that you know,
I still think about is if you
go on the unicode website,
they make a point of saying no emoji
proposal should be for a cause,
quote unquote. Um, it will be dismissed.
There are some Emoji that get adopted.
However, it's in spite of the cost,
not because of it.
And so one of the sort of lenses that
I was seeing my proposal through was
really trying to downplay
the cause factor,
which in fact when you look at that
Blue Shoe and you know me, you know,
it's a blatant Leah cause driven Emoji.
Um,
and so I had to make it as um,
as empirical and statistically
significant as possible.
And so I downplayed the actual
narrative and made it about usage,
adoption and creating a really
compelling argument for it to be made.
Fascinating.
So you're kind of all in now.
I just said you nerded out
and you love this process.
Some of us have to do it for work,
but you love this process. Um, and uh,
you're not just stopping with the Flat
Soled Shoe Emoji and you're actually,
I've heard you've actually got some
other projects in the work. Um,
and not just for men or for women,
but men as well.
I do.
This past spring I coauthored a proposal
for a one piece bathing suit because
the only swimmer option right now is an
itsy bitsy yellow polka dot bikini even
for men, even for men. And,
which is why the proposal actually
included a one piece swimsuit,
a swim trunk for men and a swim
brief for men. It's now been short,
less dead.
Oh, right. So, so when
do you hear about that?
I believe that committee
will vote in October. Um,
and if all goes well and I'll
roll out next year in 2020.
Well, if that happens, we'd
love to have you back here.
So I don't know if you know this,
but the Emoji sets like once the
unicode decides the Emoji, um,
how they're actually depicted, uh, is
up to each of the companies. But as, as,
as you pointed out,
um,
but there's a process that we have at
Google and that you could actually get
involved in if you wanted to
help do the Google version
fastly and thank you for getting swim
trunks out there because every time I
texted him, like, you know, bring
your trunks, I don't have an Emoji.
That's great.
Um,
I want you to get into some
of the other topics. Um,
you said that you see Emoji as, as
more than just, uh, just as art.
It's become, it's come language. And
you touched on it a little bit, but, uh,
we've had longer conversations,
conversations about how you see
emoji becoming part of linguistics.
I was wondering if you'd comment on
that because that was really fascinating
because none of your kids are going up.
Um,
well I'm not a an academic,
but there is a term known
as applicationary text. Um,
and so sort of thinking back to when
the original Emoji set were introduced
Emoji,
but really meant to be that aspect which
got lots in electronic messaging of the
nonverbal, so emotional,
facial, nonverbal,
accused intonation,
and you were able to supplement sort
of just the purely textural with the
nonverbal cues through an image.
Um,
and I find that really interesting
because now when we look at Emoji usage,
they don't necessarily replace where it's,
but they certainly add the meaning and
the practical meaning of a sentence.
Um, and so some would say it's part of
the linguistic channel of communication is
these nonverbal cues that you
can now include. Um, pictorially.
And so to me it's, it's one of
those really interesting things.
And that also,
I mean,
there's a reason that cliche a picture's
worth a thousand words exists. Um, and I,
I've been thinking a lot about sort of
how certain Emoji can be a time capsule
and then let themselves,
I mean,
one of the things that I didn't cover
it all is while my emoji escapades were
happening, a lot of other greater
cultural things are happening. You know,
I had my realization moment and May,
2017 and basically three
months later in August,
Melania Trump tiptoed on her
stilettos to Hurricane Harvey,
which set the whole media for roar.
And then a month later you're the Harvey
Weinstein. Me Too. Thing happened. Um,
which again, changed, change the
dialogue forever, I'd like to think.
And then in January of 2018 you got
times up happening during the Oscars.
So that was a year ago.
And then in May you had the Cannes film
festival where literally Kirsten Stewart
and the whole bunch of a actresses were
removing their shoes to walk the red
carpet. Uh, and so I'd like
to think that, you know,
30 years from now and my kids are still
seeing that little stiletto emote,
that little flat shoe Emoji that they
can sort of pinpoint exactly what was
happening on a broader cultural level.
Um,
in the same group of the Emoji that mine
was released in is the mosquito Emoji,
which to someone who doesn't
know the context of that
proposal, they might think,
why do I need a mosquito Emoji?
But then when you drill down,
you realize that it was proposed by
a team from the Johns Hopkins found
infectology team and the bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation.
And you suddenly realize that that
mosquito is there for the purpose of mass
instant global communication.
And thinking about how,
how do you communicate across countries
where maybe populations aren't literate
but completely understand this
image of the mosquito thing,
the vehicle by which diseases
transmitted. Um, again, I think, you know,
in a way this brick Emoji and the
brick wall will immediately point to a
specific moment in history,
um, and debate. And so,
um,
it's interesting to me that these
little images can actually point to
historically significant moments.
If you know the backstory to them.
One last question then we'll open
it up to everybody here in online.
But from that perspective of history,
there is a lot of criticism that the
Emoji library has gotten too large a and
even on our team and android messages,
we're thinking of new ways to let people
search and browse Emoji because it's,
it's,
you know,
it's gone from the original 400
over 2,700 and there's talk about,
you know, should some Emoji
be retired or replaced? Um,
from the perspective of history,
like what are your thoughts on that?
Should Emoji be retired or,
it's a tricky one because I can
see the unwieldiness argument,
but I also am not one
to use that argument,
um,
to justify retiring some whenever they're
sort of quantity argument comes into
play. I pointed to the fact that they're
like 13 phases of the moon Emoji.
Do we need 13 of them? Probably not.
But then it becomes a point of view,
decision making matrix. Um, and so I,
I would hate to think that the,
the minority voice or the quietest emoji
would get retired because it's usage or
adoption rate is lower than, you
know, the twinning playboy bunnies.
Um, so I think that's a
bigger question for the,
the engineers in the room
to tackle. Um, but um,
but you know,
like,
I think there's some statistic that
by the time a kid is five years old,
they've used and heard 40,000 words.
So in the context of 2100 Emoji,
yes,
it's a bit unwieldy to scroll
through and find the ones that,
that are part of your daily vocabulary.
But we're Carter.
That's great.
I'm going to grab this mic.
How did you put it out there and how did
it start to go viral in the way that it
ultimately did?
So I came up with the idea
for the Emoji in May of 2017.
I sat on it for a couple of days and then
while going to an event at the pop up
magazine,
I'm in San Francisco,
I floated at past a very close
friend who said, you should do it.
You've got nothing to lose. And
I was like, okay. Um, and then I,
because I thought, oh well, you know,
apple is the one that dictates Emoji.
I turned to a friend of mine
who worked at apple and said,
can you introduce me to someone on the
design team so they can talk to them
about this stiletto? Um, and she was like,
well actually apple doesn't determine
Emoji. The unicode consortium does.
Um, and so that's when I taught
myself how to do the proposal.
I submitted it without
really telling money.
People that I did it was one of those
things like college applications,
you don't really want to tell people
where you've applied cause you don't have
to deal with like telling them
that you didn't get in. Um,
and so there were a few close friends
who knew that I was going through the
process. Um, when I got wind
that it was getting shortlisted,
I decided to contact a friend of mine
who happened to have written a huge piece
two years prior and the Atlantic and had
gone to college with me on Stilettos.
And I called her up and I said,
I just want you to know,
and going through this process, we don't
know whether it'll get accepted or not,
but I thought, given that youth, you know,
allocated this much ink to stilettos
in the past, you might find this funny.
And she immediately got back to me and
was like, I want to write about this,
can I, can I interview you?
And I said, sure, why not? Um,
so that was in August. Um,
after the shortlisting.
And we agree to time,
the release of that article on the
Atlantic to the Friday before the unicode
committee would be voting on the Monday.
What I didn't expect is that between that
Friday morning and the Monday that New
York magazine would basically
syndicate the Atlantic piece,
that it would become the most read piece
for the next 36 hours on all of New
York magazine's website
and most shared article.
And that every single other outlet
would call me on the Monday morning.
And so by the time the committee
met Monday afternoon to vote,
they literally,
I think probably felt like they had no
choice but to face the wrath of a million
women suddenly felt this desperate
need to have a flat soled shoe Emoji,
even though they'd never realized
until that moment its omission.
And that's one of the sort of feedback
that I got also with the swimsuit Emoji
when that sort of went out in the
public domain was I was speaking to a
journalist at the times in
the UK and she said, you know,
that the day after the chief fashion
critic of the New York Times or to huge
piece about this swimsuit Emoji,
um,
our entire editorial team got together
and said, how did we miss this?
Like how did none of us realize
that the Bikini is the only one?
And I think that's the thing where Emoji
can course correct and that you've got
this incredible ability in
a fairly quick timeline.
I mean 18 months from start to finish
to enrich this vocabulary. I mean,
we're not talking about legislation which
can get bogged down through 20 years
of bureaucracy. We're talking
about a world that, you know,
it prides itself on its
agility to act fast. Um,
so that was how he did it.
We pure PR,
we bullied them into
thank you media,
you run a very successful,
uh,
yes. What are your thoughts
on the inconsistencies of
the depiction of the emojis
admitted to Unicode on the various
platforms? Obviously like apple,
Google and Facebook have all have
wildly different depictions of the shoe.
Can you talk more about your,
your thoughts and what you'd recommend if,
if you know,
a fragmentation is a good thing or if
you'd prefer consistency in your next
emoji submission. I hate the
fact that they're all different.
To me it's,
it's oxymoronic because Emoji are supposed
to be instantly recognizable between,
you know,
all the platforms.
I would love nothing more than to see it
consistently applied. Um, that's that.
I recognize that platforms have a very
distinct visual and aesthetic language.
And so,
you know,
Google has its own sort of visual
language versus apple and it would,
it would be ridiculous for me to expect
them to somehow coordinate across
platforms and agree in the consensus
style format to one singular design.
Um,
I do think it's really funny to think
about how the design aspect is rolled out.
I don't know if you've noticed,
say the jacket Emoji.
I'm on apple platform low,
eerily like a Burberry trench coat.
And then you think about the fact that
Angela Ahrendts was the CEO of Burberry
for over a decade and is now in charge
of merchandising and apple and you think,
oh, okay, I get this,
you know, like, and so,
but yet that jacket looks totally
different on apple Twitter.
And so it kind of, to me the Fi's,
the very intent behind Emoji,
which is I send my flat shoe to
someone in Chai Por who uses a Samsung.
To me those should be the
same image as, um, but again,
I think that's a coating and a brand
problem rather than an ideal world.
It would be one
I wanted to ask your opinion on.
Um,
I've heard the argument that a emojis are
actually taking us back evolutionarily
speaking linguistically
to hieroglyphics and um,
that it's a reductionist form
of language and, um, actually,
you know, the a word form
language is actually, um,
a, allows us to communicate
more, um, more freely.
Um, so I just didn't know.
Do you feel like, uh,
there is a parallel between
hierarchy hieroglyphics? Absolutely.
I think Emoji or just hieroglyphs 2.0,
um,
in terms of pictorial language,
I think the main difference though is
obviously hieroglyphs were created before
words existed in sort of the
traditional as we know it sense. Um,
and I, I think in a way, um,
if you look at that slide where they
literally translated Moby Dick into Emoji,
no one is using Emoji in that
way. Um, whether I reduces, um,
sort of vocabulary acquisition,
that's certainly a concern of mine.
And they was actually a conversation I
had with the journalists from Newsweek
who said, do you know of any
linguists or sort of, you know,
language acquisition specialist
in childhood who could
talk to me about sort of
the downside or the effects of Emoji on
young brains in zero to five because we
learn 80% of what we're going to know
our whole life in that age group. Um,
and I said, no, you know, it's, it's
such a nascent, an embryonic state,
but no one has actually done
the research yet. Um, you know,
I think about the fact that
for our generation screentime
is it going to be like
tobacco, the generation before we're
all using it and thinking it's fine.
Then 20 years from now,
all of the studies and research is going
aren't going to come out and be like,
how did you miss this?
How did you not notice the nefarious
a factor of these things on you?
And so I do wonder whether
children are children and 20,
30 years time are going to get the results
from all those academic studies that
show that Emoji,
you said screentime literacy rates are
plummeting of I'm optimistic and I'd like
to think of that. It's a won't. But um,
but I'm not an academic in that field.
I think it takes a sociologist
to figure that one out
after the,
um,
the swimsuit emojis or is there anything
else top of mind or anything else you
plan to work on? Is this going
to become like a side career?
I know now there are couple of
things that I've been searching.
I've been sort of percolating in my head.
One obvious one which I think would
be kind of a coding nightmare is that
obviously the family
Emoji stop at two kids.
And clearly I need more than that.
Um,
so I love to see an Emoji that
has two parents with four kids,
um, and maybe get, you know, large
families lobbying for it with, um,
another one,
which again I think is reflective.
My worldview is the play categories
completely missing. You know,
there's, there aren't any
slides, there aren't any swings,
there aren't any seesaws which are
very much part of my weekend existence.
Um, and certainly, um,
I've been thinking a lot about the
sort of natural disaster and natural
catastrophe category,
um,
which was sort of inspired by the
mosquito Emoji and that, you know,
if we're going to use these little
images to communicate on a broad,
massive, instantaneous, um, level,
can't we use it to alert people, turn
earthquake alert people to our tornado,
alert people to hurricane
and in one little image,
get people evacuating quickly
rather than going through, you know,
the amber alert system
for example. Um, it's, uh,
it's, it's exciting. Um,
but one of the things that does sort of
keep me up is this idea of emoji usage
eventually being mined and used to
profile people. You know, like if,
if you use the fist bump and
it's of a dark skin tone, um,
will that register you in some capacity
at an agency and lump you into one box.
Um,
and so I think if I do another Emoji,
it has to be important. Like to me,
the shoe Emoji was never about, oh,
I just want to shoot moti. Um,
it was about everything else. Um,
and I think,
um,
it's easy to lose sight of that intent
if you don't know the backstory. But, um,
I,
I say that,
and yet I was on the Unicode page last
week and I noticed in the shortlisted
list was an Emoji proposal for Fond Du,
which is someone who's half Swiss.
They designed it with a little capital,
which is a traditional sort of copper
orange pot handle with the two sticks.
And I loved it.
You know,
like the celebrity aspect is one of
the things I think that makes Emoji so
attractive and fun. And I was like, yes,
I hope that makes it because I want
that fallen to a Moochie. So, um,
you need to balance the two.
And thank you very much.
You're certainly welcome back here
anytime. I'd love to hear more.
If there's a other
Emoji that get approved,
we'll certainly be tracking them
as well. But thank you. Thank you.